wenn du willst kannst ja mal können wir
mal zusammen kurz singen können die
leute in kommentar schreiben wie split
videos in die leute was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich habe heute noch mal
die tabelle dabei die ein oder anderen
werden sie schon kennen
wir haben eben bereits ein kleines
interview bezüglich hilf mir aufgenommen
sie hat mir nämlich nachdem ich das
interview mit einer mcdonald's
mitarbeiterin gemacht habe auf insider
geschrieben dass sie mal bei deutschland
sucht den superstar und beihilfen
mitgemacht hat und da einiges zu
erzählen hat sie kommt aus österreich
und war jetzt spontan ein paar teile in
köln und da haben wir uns mal getroffen
um das jetzt zu machen und sie hat
gerade schon gesagt jetzt kommt der dsds
park und da bist du ein bisschen
nervöser meintest du gerade weil da wohl
ein paar mehr sachen vorgefallen die wir
erzählen kannst und wir werden dann mal
schauen inwiefern das alles in ordnung
ist was du sagst oder du das sagen gab
es und hoffen dass da keine rückmeldung
von der ss oder sonst nehmen kommt dass
man das video it unternehmen soll das
war der der jetzt total polarisiert hat
in der letzten schaffen ok also ich würd
sagen ich bin euch mal hier ganz kurz
vielleicht ein foto ein von dem auftritt
also ich weiß nicht ich nehme besser
nicht irgendwas aus dem originalmaterial
weil sonst wird das video nachher
gesperrt das wollen wir nicht also
einfach ein foto dann könnt ihr sehen
dass sie auf jeden fall dort mal war und
auch ausgestrahlt wurde einiges zu
erzählen hat deswegen fangen wir mal an
mit der ersten frage wie bist du darauf
gekommen zu sagen okay ich jetzt zu
deutschland sucht den superstar und
nicht zu irgendeiner anderen castingshow
the voice gibt es ja auch noch das ja
glaube ich so ein bisschen ich weiß
nicht da hat da ist ja nicht diese
gefahr so hoch dass man da ein bisschen
durch den kakao gezogen wird oder also
wie hast du gesagt oder warum hast du
gesagt ich gebe zu dass ich habe mir das
eigentlich früher immer gerne an
und habe mir gedacht ja ich will jetzt
irgendwann mal auch probieren einfach so
probieren geht über studieren ich aber
nichts zu verlieren hat dachte ich das
hat sich alles geräumt sei es ganz offen
jedenfalls ja ich war halt wieder etwas
als ich das erste mal
ich war zweimal du hast anwalt 20 20 und
ich habe mir so gedacht ach sowas
insgesamt 2 motor also nicht
ausgestrahlt da war ich aber auch schon
vor dieter bohlen beim zweiten mal
erkannt ja nicht plötzlich nicht zu fall
hast du schon mal da ja gut aber wenn da
wie viele kandidaten haben also ich weiß
nicht ich will jetzt also ich sag mal so
dass so eine sache
das hört sich vielleicht auch ein
bisschen blöd an aber selbst jetzt in
meiner position zum beispiel wenn ich
jemanden treffe der sagt jo ich kenne
ich von youtube und ich den halbes jahr
später zufällig also dass solche
situation damals noch mal hat man sagt
ja wir haben uns noch mal da und da
gesehen
das ist halt einfach manchmal nicht
möglich sich das gesicht zu merken wenn
man in der zwischenzeit schon wieder 2
300 andere gesichter gesehen hat also
das kann man entschuldigen sage ich mal
so aber natürlich manchmal kann man sich
auch merken und vor allem wenn man
länger mit der person angesprochen hat
sicherlich aber ich kenne auch kannte
auch sondern etwas bei mir gut alles
klar
weil du gerne singst
und so kann man damit machen sondern hat
sich beworben und dann haben die gesagt
komm doch mal vorbei zum casting weil es
gibt streit einfach von dieser wurde
ausgestrahlt wurde ist es gibt ja dann
irgendwie sofort castings habe ich
gehört bis man dann wirklich mal ins
fernsehen kommt oder überhaupt vor
dieser hauptjury com
und wenn man da weiter ist man halt in
köln war der zweiten vorrunde und da
sieht man dann natürlich nicht vor der
promi jury aber das ist ja allgemein
bekannt da sieht man halt vor so
irgendwelchen rtl produzenten gegen so
ein team brennt man wenn man dann wieder
weiter ist dann singt man halt dann vor
der kombi höhere dazwischen liegt er
voll viel zeit man dreht halt davor
dazwischen schon so ein interview also
erkennt es ja wie diesmal eingestrahlte
ist wenn man hinten dieses dsds ist da
vor ihm vor ihrem auftritt reden
das wird halt schon in der zweiten runde
gedreht und ja da stellen die hat dann
folgten fragen auch sehr private fragen
und muss man auch die antworten oder
kannst du dann auch sagen hey das ist
jetzt eine frage wie würde ich nicht
beantworten weil das einzige was immer
kommt so wenn ich mal gucken auch wenn
ich es wirklich sehr sehr selten gucke
aber ich bin da halt nicht so ein riesen
fan von um ehrlich zu sein
nur wenn dann da irgendeine person
auftritt da ist ja bei dieser sache dann
kommt irgendwann schicksalsschlag
das ist ja einfach einfach immer so und
ich frage mich halt wie kriegen die das
jedes mal hin dass jede person die da
auftritt gegen so einen schlimmen
schicksalsschlag die stellen dir so
viele fragen die die stellen der fragen
wie was macht dich glücklich in deinem
leben was macht dich traurig in deinem
leben wie gehst du mit niederlagen um
wie gehst du mit siegen um also die
stelle wirklich da ganz viele sehr
persönliche fragen und der clou ist du
darfst nicht einfach mit ja nein
antworten du musst dann in ganzen sätzen
antworten wenn du dich jetzt zum
beispiel fragen findest du dich selbst
hübsch und so antwort ist einfach da und
sagen wie ein bisschen ganzen sätzen
antworten dann musst du sozusagen gleich
finden sich selbst schauen weil die
frage findest du dich selbst hübsch
kommt er ganz streng
und wenn wirklich denken sich die leute
ja wieso geht die sich selbst als ist
ein beispiel irgendwie was halt so mit
welchen drei worten würdest du dich
selbst beschreiben und ich weiß gar
nicht was ich gesagt habe ich glaube ja
keine ahnung ich glaub ich bin nett ich
glaube ich bin ehrgeizig irgendwie
solche er sagt es mal so ein einsatz ich
bin dies und das und das und das haben
sie dann sind christen
naja also da muss man schon also das
sind schon ganz fiese tricks manchmal
vor allem beispiel deutschland sucht den
superstar
wenn ich das selber mal sehe und ich ja
auch viel selber mit kamera mache man
erkennt manchmal dann diese tricks ich
weiß nicht ob das jeder erkennt aber zum
beispiel wenn dann irgendwie so einen
satz fällt und dann kommt so ein gesicht
von irgendeinem jurymitglied wo er dann
eben grimassen zieht oder so und das
sind dabei die massen die kommen von
ganz woanders also weißt du die waren
gar nicht in dieser situation und dann
ist da entsteht da halt sonne so ein
komisches bild was aber eigentlich gar
nicht so war
eine frage die sehr oft gestellt wurde
bezüglich dem dieter bohlen
ob der zu dir nen etwa oder ja oder ob
er wirklich so fies ist wie es manchmal
rüberkommen im fernsehen also erst mal
bricht dort war der war total netter
denn wir sogar ein jahr gegeben war
richtig nett und beim zweiten mal wo ich
da war
da bin ich reingekommen und das erste
was er gesagt hat war fehlte dann zander
das damit seine kehrseite mich gleich
blöd angeredet weil dort vorne cordes
und was hast du dann gesagt ich habe
gesagt dass ich eine zahl gab ich habe
kurz was kann ich glaube ich habe kurz
erklärt dass ich ja das kind eine
zahnspange hatte und dass es keinen weg
gibt die wegzubekommen dachte ich damals
ich war nämlich beim jahren zahlen jetzt
seien mehrere zahnärzte mit dem alle
gesagt es gibt keinen weg die
wegzubekommen bis ich jetzt irgendeinen
fans gefunden habe der sagt das geht weg
mit krone nimmt er das auch hinbekommen
hat dass man dies angekündigt noch so
aber zu dem zeitpunkt wusste ich das
noch nicht erkannt ich noch nicht diesen
zahnarzt er das kann und wird dann halt
einfach direkt gesagt so nicht nur nicht
so heiß sondern autos nicht anders ich
glaube ja schon gesagt weiß ich was ich
kann mich noch an das allererste was er
zu mir gesagt hat so und dann doch da
kommt zeit mal die vielleicht hat das
vielleicht hat er vorher noch nie mit
zahnlücke gesehen und wenn du jetzt mal
so an deinen auftritt denkst du dahin
gelegt hast da ich mal und den dann im
fernsehen gesehen hast war das dann
deiner wahrnehmung nach der gleiche
auftritt oder dachtest du dir plötzlich
den ausstand habe ich ja ganz anders in
erinnerung also spricht die haben da
hier und da was dran gedreht um das halt
ein bisschen unterhaltsamer darzustellen
wie auch immer ich weiß ich habe den
refrain tatsächlich verkackt weil ich
war
also du hast eben gesagt du bist du
warst dann vor der jury und hat es nicht
ins recall bekomme ich nicht gekommen
und ja also die strophe war eigentlich
ganz okay soweit ich mich erinnern kann
aber der freundliche abfolge zittern in
der stimme
also ist habe ich bin ich extrem nervös
bin ich war wirklich extrem nervös und
ich hab so gezittert ich weiß ich hab
den ja frau irgendwie verkackt bei den
hohen tönen und dann habe ich aber
eigentlich gefragt ob ich noch einen
zweiten song singen darf und die man
schon ein und soja war ich kann das auch
ohne diesen buckel haben einfach
rausgeschnitten dass ich gefragt ob ich
einen zweiten song bringen darf also ja
gut und dann haben wir gesagt ja gut
nicht weiter und dann geh bitte und dann
war alles gut oder gab es während du
dann da war es irgendwie auch eine
komische situation das halt du irgendwas
gesagt hast oder die irgendwas gesagt
haben und das dann halt irgendwie so
krass dargestellt worden also dass nicht
nur mir ist aufgefallen dass die bei dem
vorsprung
es gibt ja immer diesen vorstand dass
sie der totalen blödsinn reingeschnitten
haben einmal dieses wo sie mich gefragt
habe so beschreibt sich mit drei worten
sehr gut abgeschnitten und danach wo ich
gesagt habe ich glaube ich bin ein
netter mensch und danach haben sie
reingeschnitten wie ich gerade neben
einer kandidatin gesessen bin sonntag
ich will unbedingt den recall kommen so
direkt nachdem ich glaube ich bin an der
talent so bescheuert einfach und dann
einer genau das war die beste die wir da
bin ich irgendwie dagestanden und habe
selbst ich soll mir gemacht die haben
also es war so in diesem roman die zu
mir gesagt habe hat der film jetzt eine
ankommt also wie du halt zum casting
gehst und dann haben sie so gesagt jetzt
mach mal was würdest du normalerweise
jetzt machen kann ich dafür das handy
schauen wenn ich jetzt so entlang geht
so allein
du konntest du eigentlich noch 111 ii
machen oder und da meinten die soja aber
warte mal eigentlich wollen wir doch
lieber von der perspektive drehen stelle
ich noch mal so wir gehen auch mal auf
die andere seite machen um ein set von
dir und dann haben sie dabei im vorspann
so dargestellt als würde ich da hingehen
und stundenlang celtics von mir machen
[Musik]
ich habe mich da richtig verarscht
gefühlt ja gut dass jack russell ich war
auch mal im zdf im fernsehen und ich
habe auch mal so meine erfahrung
gesammelt und ich hab' war halt auch so
vor der kamera und es war mega cool so
mit dem ganzen team und so wir haben so
richtig harmoniert und haben auch uns so
an sich wenn die kamera aus war total
gut verstanden und zwar hat dieser
bericht fertig und es war halt einfach
so ein bericht der youtuber
verallgemeinert so mega chance darstellt
einfach dass man überhaupt keinen
aufwand hat die größten rotz videos
produziert und damit so viel geld
verdient und so was halt also darum ging
es passte da irgendwie eine
aufwandsentschädigung bekommen dass sie
gesagt haben hier bezahlen
die anreise oder sonstiges
wahrscheinlich haben sie schon bezahlt
also aber nur weil du dann halt vor der
tür
aber vier sterne hotel oder war ja gut
aber immerhin hätte ich nicht erwartet
werden
pluspunkt ok alles klar ich sag mal so
du hast ja dann wahrscheinlich diese
folge auch angeguckt im fernsehen und
bis dann halt nicht weitergekommen
und ich weiss nicht dann haben
wahrscheinlich auch also dann
kamen viele negative sachen auf dich zu
wahrscheinlich kritik oder auch
beleidigungen oder so ich kann das ja
auch selber wenn ich manchmal eine
youtube kommentare lese wie bisher damit
umgegangen also passt darüber gestanden
oder war das eine schwere zeit oder
sonstwie warte jetzt mache ich es wie
der sts jetzt bin ich so richtig
traurige und ok nochmal und was schwer
und jetzt also ich hab halt echt viele
hate kommentare bekommt so sowohl auf
der einen seite als auch auf meiner
seite aber gott sei dank gab es trotzdem
noch einige leute die mir geschrieben
haben so schlimm war es gar nicht
unterwegs t sympathisch und so es kam
auch ein paar nette kommentare
nachrichten ja ich sag mal so die leute
die haben sich also leute schreiben viel
eher wenn sie irgendwas scheiße finden
dass die scheiße finden als wenn sie
irgendwas gut finden dass sie dann auch
mitteilen dass sie es gut finden
das muss man natürlich auch sagen ich
weiß nicht und was ist so das krasseste
erlebnis was du damit verbindet oder mit
diesem auftritt gibt es irgendwas was
noch so vorgefallen falls nicht dann
halt nicht ja behalten mit dem briefing
dass die einer so verarschen
obwohl sie mir schon gesagt haben wenn
du rein gehst also dachte ich mir
erzählt vom briefing jetzt mit müll
es gibt da vor so einem briefing der bis
zu unserem raum mit so einem psychiater
der bereitet sich halt auf den auftritt
von sagt ihr ganz genau wie du auf was
reagieren muss und was du sagen sollst
um zu mir haben die halten psychiater
gibt es da ja die gibt es auch dass die
geben sich wahrscheinlich aus als
psychiater nicht so panikmache oder
sofort die hat als es beim briefing hat
mir heute gesagt wenn die jury das
gemeine an die leute die noch nie was
vom briefing gehört haben das ist so
eine kleine vorbesprechungen oder so ein
kleines blatt papier wo alles mal kurz
durch gegangen wird wie es abläuft und
was das ziel ist was am ende das ist ein
produkt sein soll also so in die
richtung ungefähr also einfach ein
kleines vorgespräch sagen
die politischen ein da auch irgendwie so
dass es beim ersten mal aufgefallen die
die sagen da so sachen wie ja und du
musst auf jeden fall selbstbewusstsein
und du siehst hübsch aus und du bist gut
und du schaffst das so richtig so die
pushen also irgendwie diego ich weiß
nicht ich kann alles richtig gut
nachvollziehen weil es ja wirklich
manchmal diese auftritte gibt da denkt
man sich einfach ist denn mit den leuten
los also das ist dann halt dieses diese
eigene wahrnehmung die man hat aber
meistens können die leute da selber gar
nichts für weil sie da halt so sie haben
zu dir gesagt du musst arroganz sagen
schönen seiten zeigt lieber arrogant so
die haben auch so gesagt es bringt mir
nichts wenn du bescheiden bist und
dadurch wirst du nicht erfolgreich und
so werden die es einem ein du darfst du
schon bist du denn so arroganz sein
unterstrich ein bisschen konzern selber
ich lieber selbstbewusst und dann im
fernsehen stellt wir ein totales wenn
man so voll arrogant und ja hochmut
kommt vor dem fall
und ich glaube das machen die bei so
ziemlich allen kandidaten dass sie ihnen
sagen zeit auf jeden fall selbstbewusst
ok also du würdest soll ich mal den
meisten leuten davon abraten damit zu
machen oder was wir zu sagen ich sag mal
so du hast negative erfahrungen gemacht
es kann bestimmt auch sein es gibt ja
auch leute die es lieben gewinnen mit
die ins finale kommen und es gibt
bestimmt steht der gewinner dann vorher
schon fest und weiß nicht mehr was ich
keine ahnung man muss sich halt darüber
im klaren sein dass das fernsehschauen
ist wenn ich alles immer so ist ist
dargestellt wird ich denke es muss jeder
für sich selbst entscheiden also wenn
ihr eine gute stimme habt dann wenn ihr
damit umgehen könnte dass es vielleicht
anders dargestellt wird als es ist denn
es gibt ja auch leute die damit positive
erfahrungen haben
ich will nicht unbedingt abwarten aber
wenn die nicht sehen könnten
wenn du willst kannst ja mal gucken wir
mal zusammen kurz singen können die
leute in kommentar schreiben wie es
finden videos finden welches lied for
missing leute wir sehen jetzt mal kurz
zusammen dann könnt ihr in die
kommentare schreiben ob wir es findet
und wie er meine bezaubernde stimme und
sprachen lernen
dann singe ich es hier alle meine
entchen und du bewertet mich und dann
singst du und dann bewährt ich dich okay
okay ich fange an und angenehm warte man
muss die noch kurz kurz nicht ich fange
an alle meine entchen schwimmen auf dem
see schwimmen auf dem see köpfchen in
das wasser schwänzchen in die höh
aber ich bin auch nicht eingesungen und
ich habe die töne getroffen
ja sie ich war auch sogar im chor hatte
ich mal früher in der schule hatte ich
mal so ein kleines solo hingelegt ok
also sag's mal so ist in ordnung kann
man im tonspur bestimmt einiges
ausmachen
okay dann sag jetzt mal eben dann singt
du erst mal irgendein ballade
[Musik]
skater youtube
ich muss wirklich sagen also den anfang
von ich wirklich sehr gut
also ich bin jetzt kein musikproduzent
sei aber er hat oder ähnlich ist nur
dass weit ist jetzt vielleicht mal ganz
cool so als vielleicht die leute die
sich noch an den aufstieg ländern können
das auch mal hier zu sehen ich hätte
gedacht dass du vielleicht von ihr
selber eine andere wahrnehmung hast
weißt du ich glaube nicht dass ich die
anlage ein paar beste sängerin habe ich
glaube uns doch eher schlecht ich weiß
nicht wenn man sich da einsehen und so
also ich muss sagen der anfang war
wirklich sehr gut und ich glaube dass
wir doch jeder von den zuschauern oder
jedenfalls nicht wenn man den
kommentaren lesen bewertet werden wir
unsere gesamtleistung also meiner mama
ist gut mach weiter
man kann bestimmt da und auch noch ein
bisschen feilen aber nur weil du jetzt
herausgeflogen messe oder sonstiges
sollte man das nicht aufgeben
ok super also du hast auch ein youtube
kanal verlinkt nochmal in der video
beschreibung zwar mit dem video war sehr
angenehm ich hoffe jetzt auch gefallen
und ich hoffe ihr draußen hat es auch
spaß beim schauen
das war es jeden tag 19 uhr gibt es ein
neues video genau richtig locker
aktivieren
steckt man in sub alex wie dann kann ja
auch gerne in ihr video beschreibung
packen wie auch immer haut rein